Hallo, liebe Leute, herzlich willkommen bei
Easy German!
Wir sind heute wieder live auf YouTube und
ich sehe, wie die Zuschauerzahl sich erhöht.
Das ist schön, dass ihr dabei seid.
Ein kleiner Hinweis: Wir sind live, deswegen
gibt es keine Untertitel, aber ab morgen wird
dieses Video auch Untertitel haben.
So from tomorrow, you'll be able to turn on
subtitles.
Und vor einigen Wochen war ich hier in Berlin
live unterwegs und habe euch Berlin Prenzlauer
Berg gezeigt und war unterwegs mit so einem
mobilen Setup.
Und Cari und Janusz saßen zu Hause und haben
mir Aufgaben gegeben und Fragen gestellt und
es war wie so eine Schnitzeljagd.
Und heute drehen wir den Spieß mal um.
Und heute sind Cari und Janusz in einer Stadt,
die für uns alle besonders ist, und diese
Stadt ist Münster, denn in Münster ist Janusz
angekommen, als er nach Deutschland kam.
Cari und ich sind beide dort geboren, Isi
auch, und Easy German hat in Münster begonnen.
Und ich begrüße jetzt live aus Münster
in Westfalen: Cari und Janusz.
Hallo!
Hallo ihr beiden!
Hörst du die Kirchenglocken läuten, Manuel?
Das ist doch schon typisch Münster, oder?
Dass man pünktlich um 19 Uhr die Kirchenglocken
hört?
Warte, ich drehe mich mal um.
Guck mal, da hinten, oh, sieht man das?
Da hinten ist der Dom zu Münster.
Ist ein bisschen überbelichtet, es ist sehr
hell.
Und da gehen wir gleich noch hin, wir sind
mitten in der Innenstadt, Manuel, und Janusz
und ich, wir werden dir jetzt gleich die schönsten
Seiten von Münster zeigen und unsere persönlichen
Lieblingsorte.
Und ich habe gehört, du hast auch einige
Aufgaben für uns.
Ja, ich freue mich, es sind auch schon 600
Leute, glaube ich, ungefähr dabei.
Ihr könnt uns auch Fragen in den Chat schreiben
bei YouTube oder Facebook und dann werde ich
euch die Fragen zwischendurch stellen.
Und ein paar Aufgaben habe ich auch für euch,
aber meine erste Frage, wenn ihr jetzt gleich
losgeht, ist: Wie fühlt sich das denn an,
jetzt in Münster zu sein?
Welche Verbindung habt ihr beide zu Münster?
Also Janusz ist gestern ganz nostalgisch stundenlang
durch die Stadt gefahren mit dem Fahrrad,
vielleicht beantwortet er die Frage zuerst.
Janusz, wie fühlst du dich in Münster?
Ja, in Münster und dann ganz speziell bei
diesem Wetter einfach fantastisch.
Nostalgisch und voller Erinnerungen.
Jede Straße erinnert mich an mehrere Geschichten
aus meinem Leben.
Ja.
Egal, wo du hinguckst, ja.
Es ist schon ein Traum.
Ja.
Münster ist wahnsinnig fotogen, würde ich
sagen, wahnsinnig hübsch.
Also ich freue mich sehr darauf, dass wir
jetzt ein bisschen Münster zu Gesicht bekommen.
Wo seid ihr jetzt gerade?
Hier fährt gerade der Bus, die Nummer neun,
die fährt jetzt nach Nienberge.
Ah ja.
Wir sind jetzt gerade … Ich fange mal an
mit einer kleinen Tour hier.
Huch, huch!
Ich stöpsel mal Janusz kurz ab.
Wir sind gerade an einem für mich besonderen
Ort, wir sind nämlich an meiner alten Uni.
Hier in diesem Gebäude habe ich studiert,
das ist das "Fürstenberghaus", heißt das.
Und hier sitzen die Geschichtswissenschaftler.
Münster hat eine Uni, das ist nicht ein Campus,
sondern es gibt verschiedene Häuser in der
ganzen Stadt.
Und je nachdem, welches Fach man studiert,
ist man an ganz unterschiedlichen Gebäuden
und man muss immer mit dem Fahrrad von einer
Vorlesung zur nächsten durch die ganze Stadt
fahren.
Und dieses … dieses Gebäude hier, das Fürstenberghaus,
das ist ganz interessant, denn ich war jetzt
seit langer Zeit nicht mehr aktiv hier.
Ja.
Und als ich studiert habe, da haben wir immer
gejammert und geweint, denn dieses Haus war
eine Dauerbaustelle.
Ich hab', glaube ich, fünf oder sechs Jahre
hier studiert und es waren immer Bauarbeiten,
die ganze Zeit.
Und als ich eben ankam, habe ich gelacht.
Du siehst hier das Gerüst, dieses Haus ist
immer noch eine Baustelle.
Und mein Studium habe ich 2009 abgeschlossen.
Wow.
Das heißt, in zwölf Jahren ist diese Baustelle
nicht fertig geworden.
Wow.
Ja, Münster ist eine Studentenstadt, du hast
in Münster studiert und unsere erste Frage
von Marcia geht auch um die Größe von Münster:
"Wie viele Leute wohnen in Münster?"
Ist diese Stadt so groß wie Berlin oder ganz
klein?
Nicht ganz so groß wie Berlin.
Ich weiß allerdings nicht die exakte Zahl,
vielleicht kannst du das mal googeln.
Es sind, glaube ich, ungefähr 300… vielleicht
mehr als 300.000.
Hier wollte ich dir was zeigen.
Guck mal, ein Wahlplakat der Partei.
- 316.000, sehr gut.
316.000.
Du siehst, das ist "die Partei", eine Satire-Partei
in Deutschland.
Es ist Wahlkampf und überall hängen Plakate.
Und diese Partei macht damit Werbung, dass
es hier kostenloses WLAN gibt.
Weil das …
Es ist natürlich ein Witz, denn in Münster,
in Deutschland sowieso gibt es nirgendswo
kostenloses WLAN.
Ja, ja.
Ja, schön, okay.
Dadrunter steht noch: Glaubt nicht jedem Wahlplakat.
Ah ja, dadrunter steht noch: "Glaubt nicht
jedem Wahlplakat."
Ja, leider ist das ein Scherz.
Ja, leider ein Scherz.
Es ist ja eine Satire-Partei.
Janusz, ich möchte gerne an dich kurz übergeben.
Janusz möchte uns jetzt eins seiner Lieblingsgebäude
zeigen in der Stadt.
Ja?
Ja.
Huch!
Okay, hinter mir ist das Landesmuseum, aber
ich höre nichts.
Unter anderem.
Vielleicht muss …
Ich habe auch nichts gesagt.
- Manuel reden.
Ah, okay.
Jetzt, dieses ganze Gebäude ist für sehr
viele Millionen von Euro renoviert worden
und ist ganz toll, aber ich erinnere mich
noch an dieses Gebäude, als es viel kleiner
war und bescheidener, dafür aber umsonst.
Man d(u)rfte in dieses Museum einfach so reinspazieren
und sich alle Ausstellungen auch umsonst angucken.
Was damals für mich wichtig war, weil, ja,
ich hatte damals sehr wenig Geld und ich hätte
es mir nicht leisten können.
Später hat man das geändert und ab da musste
man Geld bezahlen.
Und das ist so traurig, weil dieses ge…
Es ist schon in Ordnung, dass man das Geld
bezahlt, man soll Geld bezahlen, man bekommt
auch jede Menge dafür.
Dieser Umbau hat auch wirklich um 18 Millionen
Euro, glaube ich, gekostet.
Ja.
Und es ist ein sehr, sehr schöne(r) Ort.
Und man kann auch eine Jahreskarte kaufen
und dann ist es, ich glaube, sieben Euro im
Monat oder so.
Es ist nicht viel und doch dann genug, um
selbst mich so ein bisschen abzuschrecken.
Und ich habe dann aufgehört, so einfach spontan
da reinzugehen, und …
Was ist denn in dem Museum?
Es … sehr viel.
Es gibt so ständige Ausstellungen mit Kunst
aus der Geschichte, auch aus (dem) Mittelalter,
aber für mich waren wichtig die Ausstellungsräume
für einfach moderne Kunstgeschichte.
Und es war …
Ja.
Es war … Es war so magisch, weil es war
so völlig un… nicht verpflichtend.
Ich bin fast jeden Tag einfach da reingegangen,
um nachzudenken.
Und ich habe mich jetzt nicht bemüht, um
diese moderne Malerei zu verstehen oder nicht
zu verstehen, aber der, die, die, die … ja,
die, das Klima, das war so angenehm.
Es war ein sehr wichtiger und ist bis heute
auch ein sehr wichtiger Ort in Münster, ja.
Das war ein schönes Plädoyer für das Museum
in Münster und eigentlich ja alle Museen,
weil sie alle diese sch… nicht alle, aber
weil viele Museen diese schöne Atmosphäre
haben und so ein Rückzugsort sind.
Und du hast einfach sehr schöne Erinnerungen
an dieses Museum.
Und hier, ich will auch … ich will auch
(ein) Plädoyer sprechen für die moderne
Malerkunst, weil wenn du in so eine Ausstellung
gehst, dann denkst du immer: "Ey, ich könnte
das auch malen."
Ja, du hast das aber nicht gemacht.
Darf ich übernehmen?
Ja.
Genau, ich denke, ihr geht mal ein bisschen
weiter und …
Wir zeigen dir mal die richtig schönen Seiten,
ne?
Bisher haben wir dir ja nur ein altes Haus
mit Gerüst gezeigt.
Und ein renoviertes, ein teuer renoviertes
Museum.
Das Museum ist schon schön.
Ist schon schön, ja.
Ja, ich würde euch auch schon mal, während
ihr noch lauft, die erste Aufgabe geben.
Frag Cari, wie viele Male sie da drin war.
Wie viele Male warst du da drin?
Janusz lacht, Janusz lacht über mich, weil
ich … ich gehe nie in Museen, obwohl ich
Geschichte studiert habe.
Cari.
Oh, Janusz hat jemanden getroffen und unterhält
sich.
Und da sehen wir auch im Hintergrund schon
ein Fahrrad und es wäre meine erste Fra…
oder meine nächste Frage und meine erste
Aufgabe für euch gewesen.
Die Frage erst mal: Warum denkt man bei der
Stadt Münster immer an Fahrräder?
Das ist eine Aufgabe?
Das ist die Frage erst mal, die Aufgabe kommt
danach.
Oh, Janusz hat noch mehr Leute getroffen.
Warum denkt man an Fahrräder?
Münster ist die Fahrradstadt, Manuel.
Ja.
Warum das so ist, weiß ich nicht.
Es ist sehr flach, man kann überall Fahrrad
fahren.
Es ist auch nah an den Niederlanden, das heißt,
die Niederländer sind ja bekannt fürs Fahrradfahren
und die sogenannten Holland-Räder sind bei
uns auch sehr populär.
Ja.
Aber weiß nicht.
Gibt es da noch mehr in der Geschichte, was
ich vielleicht nicht weiß?
Ich glaube nicht, es gibt auch einfach sehr
schöne Fahrradwege in Münster.
Und ich glaube, im Durchschnitt hat jeder
Münsteraner und jede Münsteranerin mindestens
zwei Fahrräder.
Und meine Aufgabe an euch ist, dass ihr ein
besonders schönes und ein besonders hässliches
Fahrrad findet.
Das muss nicht sofort passieren, aber im Laufe
des Spaziergangs.
Okay.
Und jetzt kannst du ja mal kurz schauen, wer
die beiden da sind.
Ja.
Hallo!
Habt ihr Lust, uns live auf YouTube zu begrüßen?
Ja, gerne!
Hallo!
- Wer bist du?
Ich bin Christine.
Christine.
Ja, ich lebe gerade in Münster.
Ah, schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Hast du ein Fahrrad zufällig dabei?
Mein Fahrrad ist ein bisschen weg, aber.
Okay.
Ich … Ich muss jetzt ein hässliches Fahrrad
finden.
Früher gab es hier sehr viele Fahrräder
an diesem Ort, aber jetzt sehe ich kein einziges,
aber das ist kein Problem, denn wir gehen
jetzt zum großen Fahrradparkplatz da vorne.
Ja, es gibt sicher …
Ja.
Janusz, wir müssen jetzt Fahrräder suchen.
Hi!
Dzień dobry!
Willst du auch unsere Zuschauer begrüßen?
Nicht so gerne.
Also, die beiden …
Kein Problem.
Die beiden haben euch erkannt, ja?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Woher kennen wir uns?
Von YouTube, okay, alles klar.
Das ist gut.
Okay.
- Janusz ist sich nicht sicher, ob sie sich
schon kennen.
Dann würde ich sagen …
Ich geh schon mal weiter …
Genau, geh mal weiter.
- Es war schön, euch zu treffen.
Bis … bis bald.
Ich werde jetzt sofort die Aufgabe erledigen,
Manuel.
Ja, ich hab' nämlich noch ein paar andere.
Gar kein … gar kein Problem.
Guck mal, das ist manchmal peinlich, dann
muss ich fragen: "Woher kennen wir uns?",
weil manchmal kennen wir uns nur über das
Internet.
Ja.
Hallo!
Ich weiß nicht, woher wir uns kennen.
Hey, kennen wir uns?
Ja, wir kennen uns aber nur von online.
Okay.
Nur online.
Hast du Lust, live auf YouTube die Menschen
zu begrüßen?
Ja, gerne.
Okay, hallo!
Hi!
- Hallo!
Ich bin Marcelo aus Costa Rica.
Marcelo!
Oh, Pura Vida!
Kennst du Manuel?
Natürlich, Manuel sehen wir jede Woche.
Jede Woche?
Ja, natürlich, eure Videos kommen ja ganz
häufig.
Richtig, ja.
Cool, guckst du unsere Videos jede Woche?
Ja, eigentlich, gestern habe ich auch eins
geguckt.
Welches denn?
Ich wollte ein bisschen noch mal gucken das
von … der Unterschied zwischen österreichischer
Akzent und Dialekten und so.
Das ist ein gutes Video.
Du hast ein schönes Fahrrad, Marcelo.
Ich habe jetzt die Aufgabe, ein schönes Fahrrad
zu suchen.
Und ich würde sagen, das hier ist der Gewinner,
oder?
Oh, da kommt grad ein Bus.
Wow!
Ist das ein Singlespeed?
Er hat sogar Handschuhe.
Frag ihn mal, ob das ein Singlespeed ist.
Manuel möchte wissen: Ist das ein Singlespeed-Rad?
Es ist auch ein Singlespeed, es ist sogar
Fixed Gear.
Wow!
Geht in beide Richtungen.
Darf ich das einmal nur anheben?
Ich bin beeindruckt.
Manuel ist direkt verliebt in dein Fahrrad,
Marcelo.
Oh, das freut mich sehr.
Sehr schönes Fahrrad.
Das (die) größte Bestätigung meines Lebens.
Die größte Bestätigung, es ist wirklich
sehr schön.
Und warum … warum ist der Lenker so breit?
Warum ist der Lenker so breit?
Ja, das stimmt.
Das kann ich mich (mir) nicht selber beantworten.
Da tausche ich immer zwischen Moods.
Und wenn ich Bock auf … so ein bisschen
mehr Rennrad zu fahren, dann habe ich einen
Triathlon-Lenker drauf.
Ach, du hast verschiedene Lenker?
So, Janusz probiert jetzt Marcelos Fahrrad
aus.
Ich fahre nicht.
Doch, fahr mal, Janusz, wir wollen das sehen.
Mal schauen wie weit ihr heute kommt.
Ja.
Solide, ne?
Darf ich mal fahren?
Ja, klar.
Janusz fragt, ob er einmal fahren darf.
So, ich bin gespannt.
Janusz fährt sehr langsam Fahrrad, wenn ich
das sagen darf.
Das ist ein Fixie … Ja, ich weiß nicht,
ob Janusz schon mal Fixie gefahren ist in
seinem Leben.
Manuel möchte wissen, ob du schon mal …
Das hat keinen Leerlauf.
Ist zu spät, es ist …
Er ist weg.
Das heißt, man kann nicht bremsen oder wie,
was heißt das?
Ja, man kann nicht nicht bremsen.
Also man muss immer mit die Pedale …
Okay.
Dein Fahrrad ist weg, Marcelo.
Deswegen wollte ich (euch) ja dann finden,
so: Das ist das beste Fahrrad.
Richtig, das … du bist gerade extra vorbeigekommen,
um uns das beste Fahrrad zu geben, und das
ist jetzt weg, ja.
Ja, jetzt machen wir ein Giveaway.
Jawoll.
Genau, das verlosen wir jetzt im Internet,
dein … Da ist es wieder.
Das war toll, danke sehr!
Ja, Marcelo, jetzt kannst du uns helfen.
Wir müssen jetzt das hässlichste Fahrrad
finden.
Oha.
Da drüben vielleicht.
Ich würde denken, vielleicht am Bahnhof,
da gibt aber sehr, sehr viele kaputte Fahrräder
und man denkt, die sind kaputt, aber die sind
(werden) immer noch gefahren.
Ja, ja.
Stimmt.
Da können wir jetzt leider nicht hingehen,
weil wir zu Fuß sind.
Wir gucken einfach mal hier.
War sehr …
War schön dich kennenzulernen, Marcelo.
Absolut wunderschön.
Janusz macht noch ein Foto.
Tschüss Marcelo!
Ciao!
Manuel sagt Tschüss zu dir.
Ciao Manuel, ciao alle meine Freunde, die
wahrscheinlich auch da sind.
Marcelo grüßt alle seine Freunde im Internet.
Schön!
Jawoll!
War schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Wir sehen uns dann im Internet.
Wir sehen uns im Internet.
Wie immer.
Tschüss!
Ciao.
Wie immer, wir sehen uns alle im Internet.
Marcelo hat ein wirklich schönes Fahrrad,
muss ich sagen, aber es wird nicht so schwierig
sein, jetzt hier ein hässliches zu finden,
denn hier stehen einige.
Dieses hier?
Janusz möchte gern dieses hier vorschlagen.
Ja, aber zu meiner Zeit … Hört man mich,
wenn ich jetzt rede?
Ja.
- Ja, man hört dich.
Also zu meiner Zeit war es gerade in oder
das war cool, hässliche, kaputte Fahrräder
zu fahren, weil keiner hat sich dadrum gekümmert.
Wie wäre es mit dem hier?
Ja.
Guck mal, nicht mal der Lenker ist noch … also
der, der Sattel ist falsch herum.
Das sieht tatsächlich schon ziemlich hinüber
aus.
Ja, ich guck mal, ich guck mal weiter, vielleicht
finden wir noch was Besseres.
Ihr müsst langsam weitergehen, die Leute
im Internet schreiben: "Aha, ihr seid am Domplatz,
ich komme gleich."
Also es könnte voll werden, wenn ihr nicht
langsam weitergeht.
Ja, guck mal, hier ist schon wieder jemand.
Möchtest du live auf YouTube die Leute begrüßen?
Ja, gerne.
Woher kommst du?
Ich komme aus Japan.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ja, schön, dass …
Weißt du, dass wir gerade live auf YouTube
sind?
Ja, ich habe … ja, vor Kurzem, ja, euer
Instagram geguckt und …
Du hast auf Instagram geguckt?
Komm, wir müssen jetzt zusammen ein hässliches
Fahrrad suchen.
Vielleicht kannst du uns helfen, eins zu finden.
Finde ich schön, dass du auf Instagram geguckt
hast und dann …
Ja, genau.
Es ist eine Teamaufgabe hier.
Und wie lange bist du schon in Münster?
Seit zwei Jahren ungefähr bin ich in Münster.
Schon so lang.
Und was machst du in Münster?
Seit … vor Kurzem habe ich meine Arbeit
angefangen in einer Kita, also.
Als Erzieherin?
Als Kinderpflegerin, also das ist eine Vorstufe.
Aha.
Ja.
Guck mal, das ist eine Mischung zwischen hässlich,
aber auch sehr schön.
Ja, das ist eher, das ist eher ein schönes
Fahrrad.
Ja.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir suchen weiter.
Jetzt sind Sommerferien an der Uni, deswegen
… ja.
Ach, Sommerferien an der Uni.
Das macht Sinn.
Deswegen gibt's keine Fahrräder.
Ja.
Wobei die richtig hässlichen … Ich habe
jetzt noch eine Geschichte für dich, Manuel,
die ist typisch Münster, ja?
Ja.
Wir sind jetzt hier auf dem Domplatz und hier
gibt es die Kathedrale von Münster, eine
schöne alte Kirche.
Ich zeige sie dir mal.
Ja.
Das ist der Dom.
Das ist der Dom von Münster und hier ist
immer mittwochs ein Markt.
Und heute waren wir hier auf dem Markt und
wir wollten, ja, mit dem Fahrrad hier hinfahren,
das Fahrrad abstellen und dann wollten Janusz
und ich was essen gehen.
Das macht man so in Münster, man geht auf
den Markt und dann trifft man dort Menschen,
weil ganz Münster ist mittwochs auf diesem
Markt und alle Leute, die man kennt, die trifft
man, ohne sich zu verabreden.
Und dann, genau hier, wollte ich mein Fahrrad
abstellen.
Pass auf: Hier ist ein Fahrradständer, hier
ist ein komisches Taxi-Zeichen, aber ich war
mir nicht sicher, wo das genau gilt.
Ich habe mein Fahrrad genau da hingestellt,
wo jetzt dieses Fahrrad steht, und während
ich abgeschlossen habe, kommt so ein Ordnungsamt-Mensch
zu mir und sagt: "Kommen Sie mal bitte mit."
Oh mein Gott.
Das heißt, er wollte mir ein Ticket geben,
weil ich mein Fahrrad falsch abgestellt habe,
nämlich auf dem Taxi-Parkplatz.
Im Halteverbot, aber daran sieht man: In Münster
sind Fahrräder mindestens genauso wichtig
wie Autos und werden auch manchmal abgeschleppt
und dann muss man sie irgendwo wieder zurückholen.
Es ist der Wahnsinn.
Also, Fahrräder sind tatsächlich … In
Berlin achtet man gar nicht da drauf.
Ja.
Als Fahrradfahrer in Berlin fühlt man sich
richtig frei, wenn man aus Münster kommt.
In Münster wird man ständig von der Polizei
und vom Ordnungsamt kontrolliert.
Ja.
Dieser Name schon, ist schon besonders, das
Ordnungsamt.
- Das Ordnungsamt.
Stimmt, da haben wir auch mal im Podcast drüber
geredet, dieses Wort "Ordnung".
Manuel, ich finde jetzt kein schlimmeres Fahrrad.
Wir müssen jetzt einfach …
Geht mal weiter Richtung Prinzipalmarkt, denn
da warten ein paar Aufgaben und Fragen auf
euch.
Okay.
Komm, wir gehen zum Prinzipalmarkt.
Manuel hat weitere Aufgaben für uns.
Ich glaube, unterwegs ist so ein Miniaturmodell
von der Stadt, das habe ich als Kind immer
geliebt.
Vielleicht könnt ihr das mal kurz zeigen
gleich.
Ja, das ist da vorne.
Das hast du als Kind immer geliebt.
Guck mal, Janusz ist am Telefonieren.
Janusz, mit wem redest du denn gerade?
Mit Michał).
Ah.
Schöne Grüße.
Liebe Grüße.
Hallo!
Ach, hallo!
Wir folgen der Facebook-Seite.
Ja.
Guck, du …
Die ist großartig.
Ein Facebook-Fan.
Möchtest du uns live grüßen?
Wir sind gerade live auf Facebook.
Hallo!
Hier ist Manuel, kennst du Manuel?
Ja.
Der ist auch in vielen Videos dabei.
Woher kommst du?
Aus Syrien.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ciao!
Ja, so trifft man sich in Münster.
Wir wollten zum Miniaturmodell.
Richtig, und dann weiter zum Prinzipalmarkt.
Ja.
Da geht es dann weiter.
Wir schaffen gar nicht unsere ganze Tour.
Ja, das macht nichts.
Es ist sehr schön zu sehen, wie viele Leute
euch kennen und wie viele Leute Hallo sagen
wollen.
Oh, da vorne kenn… da vorne ist jemand,
den ich kenne.
Ja.
Also wir haben uns heute Mittag kennengelernt.
Sie sind Easy German-Fans, aber jetzt gehen
wir mal erst zu dem Miniaturmodell, Manuel.
Hier schon mal ein Blick auf das bekannte
Rathaus.
Und hier vorne ist das Miniaturmodell, von
dem du sprichst.
Das ist das kleine Miniaturmodell.
Ich finde es sehr schön.
Hier ist der Dom.
Immer noch.
Super schön, ne?
Ja.
Hast du hier eine Aufgabe oder soll ich weitergehen?
Nee, du kannst mal weitergehen Richtung Rathaus
und dort wartet dann eine Aufgabe auf euch.
Auf dem Weg dahin kannst du mal kurz erklären,
warum das Rathaus so wichtig ist.
Das Rathaus ist wichtig … erst mal ist es
sehr schön.
Ich zeig dir das noch mal von hier.
Es ist leider … es muss irgendwie … ich
bin sehr schlecht dadrin.
Guck mal, hier sieht man das jetzt, ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist so ein, wirklich so ein altes Giebelhaus
aus dem Mittelalter.
Und es ist ein besonderer Ort, denn hier ist
der Westfälische Friede geschlossen worden,
der Dreißigjährige Krieg wurde hier beendet
1648.
Und weil Münster eine der wenigen Städte
war, die nicht zerstört wurden im Krieg,
haben in diesem Rathaus die Menschen verhandelt
über den Frieden.
Das ist der historische Aspekt dieses Rathauses.
Der Aspekt, der mir am meisten in Erinnerung
ist, ist, dass auf der Treppe vor dem Rathaus
meistens ein Straßenmusiker ist.
Richtig.
Das war jahrelang immer der sehr bekannte
Straßenmusiker Onkel Willi.
Ist der … Ist gerade ein Straßenmusiker
da?
Denn wenn …
Da sind zufällig gerade Straßenmusiker.
Ich filme sie einfach mal, denn ich habe sie
heute schon kennengelernt.
Janusz ist ganz gerührt.
Voll schön.
Oh, ich darf Janusz nicht filmen.
Erzähl mal die Anekdote, wie du sie heute
kennengelernt hast.
Willst du nicht im Internet erscheinen?
Janusz hat Tränen in den Augen, weil er so
gerührt ist.
Ist das nicht süß?
Willst du nicht Manuel erzählen, warum?
Nee.
Erzähl.
Also wir haben uns heute kennengelernt.
Janusz und ich sind hier heute hier rumgelaufen
und plötzlich kam jemand auf uns zugerannt
und sagte: "Hey Cari, hey Janusz!"
Und dann kamen noch zwei Leute mit ihren Instrumenten
in der Hand.
Ja.
Und das waren die beiden, die da sitzen.
Verrückt.
Und haben einfach nur Hallo sagen wollen,
weil sie Easy German-Fans sind.
Ich …
Zeig noch mal die Musik, genau.
- Zeig sie dir noch mal.
Ja.
Mega schön.
- Schön, oder?
Vielleicht kommen sie ja gleich noch mal und
dann können wir sie vielleicht vorstellen.
Cari.
Janusz, mein Schuh ist offen, ich muss mal
ganz kurz … darf ich ganz kurz an dich übergeben?
Ja, aber ich bin gerade sehr bewegt.
Erzähl uns das, das wollen wir unbedingt
hören.
Ja.
Ja, warte.
Oh ja.
Erzähl, warum bist du so bewegt?
Keine Ahnung, weil es einfach so schön ist.
Ich bin überwältigt.
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist ja ein Ort, der
für dich sehr, sehr besonders ist, weil du
hier auch angekommen bist quasi, oder?
Jetzt hört er mich gar nicht mehr.
Ja, jetzt hört er uns nicht mehr.
Janusz.
Ja.
Möchtest du uns vielleicht jetzt …
Ich habe das vorhin im Intro erwähnt, dass
du hier quasi angekommen bist, als du von
Polen nach Deutschland kamst.
Ja, nicht nur das.
Als ich das … Wir sind mit dem Zug angekommen.
Jetzt musst du applaudieren.
Bravo!
Wir sind mit dem Zug … Okay, ich wollte
eine Geschichte erzählen, ganz kurz.
- Warte, ja.
Also wir, weil ich bin mit einem Freund nach
… hierhergekommen und wir sind ausgestiegen
am Bahnhof und dann mit einem Bus, mit so
einem Bus, wie, den ihr da seht jetzt, ja,
sind wir hier entlanggefahren und das war
am 14.
August abends.
Und die… diese Menschen, die ihr da seht,
saßen genauso draußen und es gab ganz wunderbare
Beleuchtung hier.
Und ich guckte aus dem Fenster von dem Bus
und dachte: "Ich möchte hier gerne bleiben,
das ist ein sehr schöner Ort", ja.
Und vor wie vielen Jahren war das?
Vor 37.
Wahnsinn.
Das kann ich verstehen, dass du da nostalgisch
bist.
Ja, total.
Okay, ich muss mich jetzt kurz ausklinken,
ciao.
Ciao.
So, ich habe mittlerweile mit den beiden Musikern
gesprochen.
Hallo ihr beiden!
Hallo!
Ihr seid gerade live auf YouTube und hier
ist Manuel.
Seht ihr Manuel?
Ja.
Kennt ihr Manuel?
Hi!
Ihr kennt Manuel wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ja.
Cool, erzählt mal, woher kommt ihr und seit
wann macht ihr Musik?
Wir kommen aus Brasilien und wir sind hier
in Deutschland seit Oktober 2019, ja?
Seit fast zwei Jahren.
Fast zwei Jahre, ja.
Wir machen hier einen Master in Musik.
Den Master in Musik?
Ja.
Wow.
Und wir, wir … also, spielen Cello seit
… 15 Jahren?
Wir spielen schon lange, 15 Jahre.
Ja.
15 Jahre spielt ihr schon?
Ja, seit 2006, ganz genau.
Und wie gefällt es euch in Deutschland?
Ich bin sehr glücklich hier, auf jeden Fall.
Ja?
Das ist schön.
Ihr macht wunderschöne Musik.
Immer noch.
Ja, es freut uns sehr.
Viel Spaß euch!
Vielen Dank!
Danke.
Wir machen euch weiter Musik.
Das ist schön.
Manuel, hast du noch eine Frage oder eine
Nachricht?
Liebe Grüße vom ganzen Internet an die beiden.
Liebe Grüße vom ganzen Internet, möchte
Manuel …
Liebe Grüße, liebe Grüße an alle.
Ciao!
Cari, eine Frage, die schon mehrmals in den
Kommentaren stand, bezieht sich auf die Kirche,
die wir jetzt hinter dir sehen.
Das …
Wir haben mittlerweile noch mehr Leute getroffen.
Oh.
Hallo!
Wollt ihr das Internet grüßen?
Hallo Cari und Janusz!
Hallo, wer bist du?
Ich bin Susanne.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Jetzt haben wir hier Musik und viele Leute,
die hier sind.
Hallo!
Okay, geht mal weiter, bevor wir eine Versammlung
starten.
Schön, euch zu … kennenzulernen.
Vielleicht könnt ihr Richtung Innenstadt
gehen und …
Ja, wir müssen … wir müssen jetzt hier
… Hier sind viele Leute, Manuel.
Ja, ja, es geht jetzt ab.
Und währenddessen … - Ja, wir werden jetzt
…
Kirche, Richtung Kirche müsst ihr gucken,
ne?
In das … die Kirche, ja?
Die zeigen wir jetzt.
Janusz!
Okay, ich lasse Janusz zurück.
Genau, der kommt dann nach.
Die Kirche, die du grad gezeigt hast, das
ist die Lambertikirche und an dieser Kirche
hängen oben an dem Turm so drei Käfige.
Und mehrere Menschen haben sich schon gewünscht,
dass du sie einmal zeigst und kurz erklärst.
Dass ich da hochgehe.
Nee, bitte nicht, aber dass du kurz erklärst,
was es mit diesen Käfigen auf sich hat.
Okay, ja, das ist gar nicht so einfach, denn
ich habe zwar Geschichte studiert, aber mir
nicht alles gemerkt.
Also hier … Ich gehe noch mal näher ran.
Ja, ja, geh mal ein bisschen näher ran.
Ja.
Also die …
Manuel, wie fühlst du dich?
Also, es ist … es ist fantastisch, es ist
wirklich fantastisch.
Münster ist wunderschön, sehr fotogen und
ihr erlebt tolle Sachen.
Es ist wirklich wunderschön.
Guck mal, wie schön die Häuser hier sind.
Ja, ja, diese Fassaden in Münster, das ist
einfach unglaublich.
Hier siehst … Ah, hinter der Baustelle gibt
es die ältesten Häuser.
Wir werden jetzt ganz kurz diese Käfige hier
vorstellen.
Sieht man die überhaupt?
Ja, nicht wirklich.
Man sieht sie ganz klein.
Da oben über der Uhr, da sind drei Käfige,
genau.
Richtig.
Also das hier ist die Lambertikirche und vor
ungefähr … mal kurz rechnen, 500 Jahren
gab es hier eine Gruppe in Münster, die hießen
die Täufer.
Und die haben, ja, die waren so ein bisschen
religiös extrem drauf und haben diese Stadt
beherrscht und hier ihre kleine eigene, ja,
wie nennt man das?
Ihr religiösen … religiöse Sekte hier
ausgebreitet in Münster.
Und irgendwann wollten die Münsteraner die
nicht mehr haben, sie haben sie besiegt und
vertrieben.
Und die drei Führer von dieser Gruppe, die
wurden hier oben in diese Käfige gesteckt,
damit … als Abschreckung, Manuel.
Das Wort ist schwierig.
Abschreckung heißt, jeder sollte diese Leute
im Käfig sehen und sehen: Wenn ihr böse
Sachen macht in der Stadt, dann landet ihr
im Käfig.
So war das im Mittelalter.
Cari, wenn du jetzt weiter geradeaus gehst,
ja?
Ich habe Angst, dass Janusz mich nicht mehr
findet.
Der kann mich ja jetzt auch nicht anrufen.
Er steht da vorne … - Er könnte natürlich
einfach auf YouTube schauen, wo du gerade
bist, aber.
Der steht da vorne und … umringt mit einer
Traube von Zuschauern.
Oh Gott.
Ich winke ihm mal.
Janusz!
Warte, halt dir mal kurz die Ohren zu.
Sag ihm mal, dass wir schon zum Ende kommen.
Ich kann nicht so hier laut sein, hier sind
sehr viele Leute.
Ist das Fernsehen?
Wir sind live bei YouTube.
YouTube?
Wollt ihr jemanden grüßen?
Ja, ich grüße meine Mutter.
Ich grüße auch seine Mutter.
Schön.
Und seine Tante.
Ich … ah ja, Janusz sieht mich, okay.
Ich winke hier die ganze Zeit.
Manuel, wo willst du uns noch hinschicken?
Wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Genau, geh mal Richtung Lambertikirche und
dann rechts um die Ecke.
Und während du da hingehst, würde ich gerne
einen kurzen Videoclip zeigen.
Der ist schon ein paar Jahre alt und dieser
Videoclip, der ist, ja, wie viele Jahre, 15,
16 Jahre alt?
Das ist Episode 1 von Easy German, der ist
dort entstanden.
Und Episode 1 von Easy German, da ging es
darum, dass die Moderatoren, unter anderem
auch Janusz kurz, einfach nur Hallo gesagt
haben.
Und ich zeige … ich zeige mal kurz den Clip.
Ja.
Und eure Aufgabe ist es jetzt …
Ich kann euch zeigen, wo wir das gemacht haben.
Genau.
Und eure Aufgabe ist es jetzt an dieser Stelle,
das Gleiche noch mal zu wiederholen.
Natürlich dürfen wir die Leute nicht ohne
Zustimmung zeigen, aber wir sehen euch dann
ja.
Und ihr sollt jetzt also mal ein paar Leute
auf die gleiche Art und Weise begrüßen wie
bei Easy German Episode 1.
Kein Problem, wir sagen einfach Hallo, ja?
Hallo, wie geht's?
Die Basics.
Okay, kein Problem.
Also wir gehen jetzt in die Straße rein.
Oh, das ist jetzt peinlich, ich habe den Namen
der Straße vergessen.
Salzstraße.
Hier wurde früher Salz gehandelt, Manuel.
Hier ist die Straße, du siehst, es sind nicht
so viele Leute unterwegs, aber … Es ist
ja 19:30 Uhr, Shopping ist vorbei.
Die Leute essen jetzt Abend.
Ja.
Richtig.
Um diese Zeit, ja.
Du kannst zwischendurch auch noch ein bisschen
über …
Janusz möchte anfangen.
Okay, dann legt los.
Ich habe das Gefühl, mein Handy geht hier
raus, warte.
So, du möchtest anfangen, Janusz?
Ja.
Okay, fang mal an.
Hallo Thy und Trang.
Aber du sollst nicht in die Kamera sprechen,
du sollst die Leute …
Das war die Anmoderation.
Hallo!
Wie gehts?
Bestens, danke.
Bestens?
Das ist sehr schön.
So, wir begrüßen jetzt alle Leute in dieser
Straße, Manuel.
Das ist wunderbar.
Ja.
Hallo!
Hey!
Nicht reagiert, war beschäftigt.
Schade, dass nicht so viele Leute hier sind.
Nicht so viele Leute da, ne?
Hi!
Hallo.
Hallo!
Guten Abend.
Hallo, hi!
Moin moin aus Oldenburg.
So, Manuel.
Ja, toll.
Wie viele sollen wir noch?
Sind wir schon fertig?
Nee, habt ihr bestanden, die Challenge.
Habt ihr …
Oh, hier werden gerade Wahlplakate aufgefangen
(aufgehängt).
Oh, jetzt noch?
Von Christian Lindner.
Hallo!
Am 26., FDP.
Sie sagen, wir sollen am 26. die FDP wählen.
Wird nicht passieren.
Pscht, das wissen die ja nicht.
Cari, während ihr noch durch diese wunderbare
Straße lauft, wir müssen schon langsam zum
Ende kommen.
Hallo.
Erzähl doch bitte noch mal ein bisschen:
Was ist typisch münsteranisch vielleicht,
es … Mehrere Leute haben gefragt: Gibt es
etwas Typisches zu essen vielleicht aus Münster?
Und habt ihr noch Anekdoten aus eurer Zeit
in Münster, die ihr noch erzählen könnt?
Janusz, was ist typisch Münster?
Oh, wo sind die … siehst du diese Dinger?
Janusz möchte euch ein Denkmal zeigen, es
gibt das aber noch auf dem Boden.
Also typisch für Münster ist, dass die Leute
sehr entspannt sind, auch sehr nett.
Hast du ja gesehen, jeder hat gerade Hallo
gesagt, aber … YouTube, ja.
Willst du mal Hallo sagen?
Hi!
Wie heißt der Kanal?
Easy German.
Easy German?
Ja.
Ich guck mal vorbei.
Guck mal vorbei.
Ciao!
Also typisch für Münster ist, dass die Leute
sehr nett sind, aber auch sehr korrekt, so
wie zum Beispiel, dass heute dieser Typ kam
und gesagt hat, dass ich mein Fahrrad falsch
geparkt habe.
Das ist typisch Münster, so was würde in
Berlin nie passieren, dass jemand herumgeht
und guckt, ob die Fahrräder korrekt geparkt
sind.
Das stimmt.
Und das war nicht …
Oh!
Das Gleiche ist beim letzten Stream auch schon
passiert.
Da hat sich vermutlich die App geschlossen
von Cari.
Ich glaube, es ist auch um die gleiche Zeitmarke
bei mir passiert, deswegen hoffe ich mal,
dass sie zurückkommt.
Und da sehe ich, sie ist wieder da, fantastisch.
Die App ist abgestürzt, Manuel.
Ja, komischerweise nach 38 Minuten.
Das war bei mir beim letzten Mal auch so.
Echt?
Ich glaube schon.
Vielleicht ist das das Maximum.
Kann sein.
Ja, auf jeden Fall ist das typisch Münster.
Danach haben wir diesen Mann noch mal gesehen
und er hat Fahrräder einfach korrekt hingestellt.
Also es gab Fahrräder, die geparkt haben,
und er hat korrigiert, wie diese Fahrräder
geparkt …
Damit sie gerade stehen.
Damit sie alle gerade in einer Reihe stehen.
Das ist typisch Münster, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ja.
Janusz möchte noch einen letzten Ort zeigen.
Oh ja, sehr gerne.
Dann müssen wir uns in Bewegung setzen.
Guck mal, hier.
Ach, das hier.
Hier stand so ein Denkmal mit so riesigen
Fahnen, die quasi in verschiedene Weltrichtungen
gezeigt haben, je nachdem, nach der Windlage.
Aber es ist noch ein Kreis hier.
Oh, genau.
- Hier sind all die Partnerstädte von Münster.
Ja.
Man sieht, wie viel Kilometer entfernt.
Genau.
Zum Beispiel York in England.
600.
Da, wo unser Freund Ben aufgewachsen ist.
600 Kilometer.
Fresno.
Dann haben wir Orléons in Frankreich, 600
Kilometer.
Ja, das sind … Fresno ist in Kalifornien.
Spannend.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Ich sehe gerade, ich habe ein paar Kommentare
hier verpasst in der Zwischenzeit.
Ja, live, Livestream.
Ja klar, komm und sag Hallo zu uns.
Du hast Kommentare verpasst, okay.
Erzähl mal.
Klaus, unser lieber Freund Klaus, der auch
in Münster lebt, hatte noch euch aufgetragen,
ein Bier zu kaufen für die Musiker.
Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich zu spät.
Oh, schade.
Aber das könnt ihr ja später noch machen.
- Klaus wollte, dass wir den Musikern ein
Bier kaufen.
Das ist auch typisch Münster, hier ist es
nicht wie in Berlin, es gibt keine Spätis
in der Stadt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man hier Bier kaufen
kann.
Stimmt.
- Ich weiß …
An der Tankstelle.
Die drei Plätze, die man hier hat, aber das
…
Janusz kennt alle drei Plätze, wo man Bier
kaufen kann.
Natürlich.
Ja, ich denke, wir müssen langsam zum Ende
kommen, aber es war eine wunderbare Tour …
Lass uns jetzt, uns bewegen, weil ich will
euch noch die Bücherei zeigen.
- Durch Münster.
Ach, die Münsterei.
Janusz möchte uns gern noch die Bücherei
zeigen, aber wir müssen jetzt aufhören,
Janusz.
Okay, dann nächstes Mal.
- Das wird … Dann müsstet ihr jetzt …
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr in Münster seid,
dann besucht einmal die Bücherei, die ist
unglaublich.
Das ganze Gebäude ist nachempfunden einem
Schiff und es gibt dort nicht nur Bücher,
sondern auch riesige Räume, wo ihr euch entspannen
könnt und einfach chillen könnt.
Stimmt, da gibt es sogar so Orte, wo man Hörbücher
hören kann.
Ich bin froh und stolz auf dieses Ding.
Okay, da können wir ja vielleicht noch mal
kurz hingehen, während Manuel schon die Abmoderation
einleitet.
Abmoderation, okay.
Also ich bedanke mich erst mal ganz herzlich
bei euch beiden, dass ihr uns Münster gezeigt
habt und dass ihr euch jetzt beeilt.
Außerdem bedanke ich mich an (bei) alle(n)
Zuhörer*innen und Zuschauer*innen, die spontan
jetzt per Video erschienen sind und euch besucht
haben.
Voll nett, ne?
Total nett und cool.
Dann natürlich ein riesiges Dankeschön an
Isi und Francisco, die hier im Hintergrund
die Organisation und die Technik übernommen
haben, wie so oft.
Polizei.
Vielen Dank auch an die Polizei.
Und dann möchten wir uns natürlich bedanken
bei unseren Mitgliedern auf Patreon, denn
die machen das möglich, dass wir diese und
andere Dinge machen, unsere Videos, unseren
Podcast.
Wenn ihr auch ein Mitglied werden wollt, dann
geht das auf patreon.com/easygerman.
Danke schön an alle von euch und liebe Grüße.
Wir haben heute ein Mitglied von uns, einen
Patron, auch hier in der Stadt getroffen.
Wow, ja, das sind schöne Momente.
Was ist das?
Janusz ist verschwunden.
Oh Gott.
Janusz?
Okay, ich gehe jetzt alleine zur Bücherei.
Ja.
Janusz?
Ich habe den Überblick verloren, wo du überhaupt
bist.
Janusz hat mich verloren.
Du hast den Überblick verloren, Manuel?
Ja.
Guck mal, in der Bücherei gibt es jetzt Corona-Schnelltests.
Das, diese Frage kam auch, wie die Lage ist.
Also wir haben ja gesehen, die Menschen sind
auf der Straße.
Wie ist die Corona-Situation?
In Münster, glaube ich, ganz in Ordnung.
So, hier ist jetzt die Stadtbücherei.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde das Gebäude jetzt
nicht so schön.
Ja, ich glaube, es sind vor allen Dingen nostalgische
Erinnerungen.
Ich war auch als Kind häufiger in dieser
Bücherei und dann hat man natürlich schöne
Erinnerungen daran.
Und sie ist von innen toll, also sie hat viele
schöne Ecken und Räume.
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Ja, hier ist dieses schiffsähnliche Gebäude,
das Janusz meinte.
Ja.
Na gut.
Ihr beiden, hast du Janusz wiedergefunden
oder ist er weg?
Janusz steht da vorne und quatscht.
Hallo!
Leute winken uns zu, ich weiß aber nicht,
ob sie einfach so zufällig winken.
Ich habe ja … Hi!
Ich habe ja eben auch allen zugewunken.
Die Leute sind einfach nett hier.
Die Leute sind nett.
Cari, ich lasse euch jetzt quatschen mit den
Leuten auf der Straße und wünsche euch eine
…
Ich sage noch schnell Janusz … du kannst
noch schnell Janusz Tschüss sagen.
Das ist gut.
Janusz, bitte verabschiede dich von deinem
Publikum.
So, es war wunderschön.
Ich würde das am liebsten zweimal in der
Woche machen.
Ja, machen wir demnächst, dann machen wir
einen Live-Kanal, Janusz …
Können wir ja machen.
"Janusz läuft" nennen wir den.
Ja.
Genau.
Es war toll mit euch, Manuel.
- Es war toll, bis bald!
Liebe Grüße.
Es war unglaublich.
- Danke schön!
Woher kamen all die Leute, die uns kannten?
Hast du sie bestellt oder …
Ciao!
Tschüss!